okay oh we got some big dogs in here we
got some big dogs let's enter that here
we go wow what was that it said it I
entered late I might not get paired up
nineteen seventeen nineteen Twenty
twenty two nineteen twenty two twenty
two twenty two twenty three twenty three
the average rating is twenty-one
twenty-three and it's very simple to
beat me tune in to the stream and listen
if you do that shame on you wait I think
this guy beat me last time
be nga he definitely gave me a beating
the last time I competed I might have to
start throwing out some duds I'm not
going to tell you my plans so if you're
listening first and foremost
shame on you mute it okay let's go
they're giving me a time edge I think
was this the guy was pairing up with the
first round the last time we will see we
will see already
let's go Queen's Gambit all right oh it
is the same person they're throwing out
a draw that's the tail right there
they're throwing out these drawers and
that happened last time and I have
experience with this line those of you
that were around to watch the beatings I
took against the impossible one the
computer impossible let's get my Queen
here looking for a floor can I get a
four in what's the what's the trick hmm
let's try it it's my night gonna get
pinned it is oh that's okay
all right so how about just push here I
accomplishing anything by doing that
let's see t 5 D 5 D 5
everybody loves D 5 or do they um let's
see if I take let's do that if I take
what would have happened like eventually
the bishop plays here okay
I'm probably in trouble I should Castle
now or put a question in this Bishop hmm
what do I take take first and then uh
yeah I like taking first they're gonna
give me the d5 square no they're
watching over that's why they captured
with that pun like that mmm so now let's
do this get out of that pin before it's
too no they're not gonna capture like
that one why would they ever do
something like that so what now what now
what now what now how about this is good
maybe um hopefully this works out where
I could pinpoint the EEP on I want my
rook on see it's get it opposite to
clean so maybe there's tricks and I hear
Bishop takes pawn type of stuff maybe I
could I want to get out of this pin soon
and my opponent is they have a good
position here tonight right there I
guess is gonna be coming up okay
interesting decision now
I'm gonna try and get play on the F file
my bishop is already bearing down there
I'm gonna play h3 okay I think this was
not a good choice for my pawn I could be
mistaken but let's give it a whirl here
let's give it a whirl watch over this
pawn I want didn't my bishop is valuable
I don't know if the knight move is good
and if I'm recalling last time my
opponent plays fast and I have to take
that into account so I have to if I
really want to win I have to do maybe a
little bit less talking here I have this
knight move available I wonder if it's
any good right now this is probably a
good one to start off with though isn't
it
pick up the bishop here and get doubled
f7 is a bit tender there isn't it and
what about this this has to be better
for me right because of what because I
have the more active Bishop in an
opposite color Bishop pending that's
exactly we're gonna want to have
so the real could play to the seventh
rank I could be losing this pond but I
think I'm crashing through on f7 if they
run with that rook here there's the the
rook and Bishop are kind of sectioned
off to this quadrant so we're about
equal with the time and I'm assuming
that they're getting ready to push this
pawn so what can I do about that let's
let's do this first have them make that
move and then and then I want my Queen
to get to g6 and then I'm gonna look for
mate actually there was something even
better
okay my clean has to play here it's
definitely the move and now I'm
threatening to actually take this pawn
right here on e5 rook takes e5 so
let's see what are they gonna do we're
about equal with time and I think guy
tricked them or did I know I wasn't
really gonna take here I was just
bluffing that one hoping that they were
listening on the street man okay I was
thinking rook takes rook takes rook
takes pawn takes Queen g8 mate but I
still have that up my sleeve and it's
happening
coming down now right now oh this has to
be good
rook takes Oh all the bishop is here to
watch over that ah I don't have anything
crap I miscalculated oh and this pond is
gonna be really quick isn't it ah man I
don't have anything I thought I had
tactics that were working out for me
but they aren't uh yeah why aren't they
working out bishop here's no good Queen
check and then it's picked off God if I
don't have anything right away I'm dead
do I have anything right away
it's not working out
ah w is a far-off here this idea right
here was just wrong wasn't it
run King come on you know you want to
run you know you want to run king uh-oh
do I have tricks up my sleeve do I have
tricks up my sleeve
h7 oh the Kings gonna get flushed out a
little bit maybe maybe oh they're down
on time Queen h4 they're just gonna run
like a bandit they're gonna run like a
bandit maybe I should go for a draw
come on you know you want to draw I'm
down in time it'll be a better start to
the last time I played or I got a loss
the Big L oh look at that
that can't be good they're gonna be
ready to karate chop my uh wonder what's
that move that's not working now I still
got me the rook is bearing through now
look at this F file this rook is around
right here rook f7 Oh
bad things are happening halt to my
opponent I got them I'm calm I'm
counting the chickens before they hatch
on this one rook takes g2 I'm smashing
this open smash it open crashing through
there's no defense
or is there Queen g7 now that doesn't
work either I could give a check a ruski
and then a pin ruski on f7 okay oh oh
did I get a double you there's no maid
on g2 let's do that okay let's do this
let's do that and go fast I got 25
seconds I don't want to lose a game
after I've already counted those chick
a check I got a burn some time check
again
let's get behind that pun and let's take
it let's give another check and another
check and push
let's come over here I want that H fun
let's take that and this pin let's do
that never catch both of them are they
gonna resign I gotta watch out for a
stalemate watch it turn out to be
stalemate oh let it be stalemate please
no stalemate let's come over here hang
on hang on
stalemate natan to like you to take me
to cut down to three point five seconds
oh man okay back to the tournament look
at that I don't even get any a chance to
breathe here I don't get a chance to
breathe Ellard game going on oh man that
guy had me on the ropes I don't think he
should maybe not I don't know if they
should have allowed my bishop to sneak
around there - oh that f5 square oh okay
here we go
no no I don't want to resign the game
let's do this I was just trying to
double the points there how awful with
yeah I resigned after move one that
would have been painful yeah okay you
know it's coming I've played this that's
that that's what happens when you play
too many war zones I was talking about
that earlier in the stream I was
clicking on that resign button like I
just did not even want to play this guy
and I think this is the guy that beat
the guy that beat me twice earlier in
this stream did you catch that I'm
playing the guy that beat me two out of
three times now how can I beat this guy
if that's been going on so I'm looking
for a four and I'm looking for Queen a
five and I want the Queen's to come off
because in the caro-kann that's usually
beneficial let's see if that is actually
true
if I win it's true and if I lose it's
not true so hang tight my opponent wants
a try
let's decline that I want to play maybe
I should have accepted accepted the job
rook here see what they want to do let's
give it a whirl
flip their clock keep ticking it be it
really would be nice if I could just
have my opponent you know like you know
what am I trying to say have my opponent
[Music]
low on time okay let's do this looking
for f5 and how do we capture now this is
a big decision um if I take like this
this is usually what I do but I think
this pond becomes really quick
it's a passed pawn so a big decision
here I take my rook now if anything the
pond and then maybe I could get this
structure in a little bit scary but I'm
gonna go for it I'm gonna go for it
because I did not like that each pond
getting passed so I'm not doing it just
because hey I want on double my pawns
now it's it's more to it than that
so if I do this there
to do that to stop my night from getting
to this square I think I think I think I
think I think let's go here first I want
to get in I think a rook rook rook here
about this or actually let's do this I
was thinking about rook da but I didn't
like pawn push with like forks even
though my knight is here for right now
I kinda don't want to rely upon my
knight to have to watch over a square so
I'm assuming Bishop f3 is gonna be
pretty strong let's do this and think
later
that's oh this this isn't a good move I
don't think cuz this is the pond move
that my opponent wants to get in but now
they can't really get that in I could do
this followed by Knight b6 to d5 is that
actually a decent idea or should I do
this first no I don't like that I think
there's like a take and if I take like
this pawn wash pawn push pun wash upon
or pawn push or like Bishop h5 let's not
do that
how about this okay if they push this
here how do I get my knight to this
square well I have to make this happen
somehow let's get my knight here for
just a second and okay yep
hmmm let's do this I'm sensing that that
ponds gonna be targeted really soon so
let's get out of that nonsense I'm in
trouble by the way if you didn't realize
I'm in trouble here I'm playing out like
three ranks of of the board here which
is not fun I usually want to play in a
different way so okay let's let's do
this let's make them think hopefully
they're not burning any time and let's
do this maybe I could get this move in
if they move their book okay let's gonna
go for a draw for a drop no how many
times are we gonna hit that thing I'm
offering a trial repetition okay I'm
gonna take it there's no way there's no
way that I'm better in this position I'm
gonna take my little draw and take it to
Round three okay is it all right that I
do something like that if you're upset
with me for doing that then I don't know
what to tell you because what's that one
phrase I came across it in one chest
book though you tried to count more a
cat's legs are still four it's a little
bit weird sounding button whatever
what's the point of it anybody known the
twitch chat let's go to another game
that's going on who's uh who's going on
this is a big one there's some heavy
hitters here let's maybe come up with
some strategy let's see what their
opening was I might be playing against
one of these so I'm doing some home prep
right here I'm cooking okay white played
e4 and then we had the Carroll con d6
the thing keeps shifting on me I can't
keep it in place we had whoa see oh no
it was c4 excuse me efore c6 c4 Oh like
a pan of Botvinnik alright and then
black responded d6 + e5 oh okay it's
like an anti caro-kann
all right so who's gonna be the winner
here we know who has the safer King
Black has the safer King and this rook
is ready to drop the hammer on the
position
oh look to see two bad things happening
though you try to count more cat's legs
are still four don't try to get more out
of position than what is really there so
seventh rank what happened to the white
F pun ooh but wait a second of nice
resource kin white hang on for a draw
here I think h4 is interesting opening
up a diagonal towards that white king mm
maybe I shouldn't be commenting on these
games yeah I probably shouldn't because
they might be listening in and they
might have an edge
somehow at every every third comment
might be actually decent we're gonna
have a drop Queen c5 what is that doing
oh the Queen the ladies are off or no
the rooks are off excuse me so I think
this is a draw if anything of course
black is trying for a win let's see the
speed they're about equal with time
who's gonna slip up here black is just
making sure everything is intact white
clock is ticking three two one almost
just a minute left
oh did we make it oh man
that hurts I didn't even see that one
apparently neither did white ouch it
happens though it definitely happens man
that one definitely hurts it happens
though it definitely happens okay so Oh
sorry if I got loud right there too so
these things happen when certain moves
kind of just blow my hair back and that
one did that one caught me off guard
there so let's see what's going on here
against mr. M Lutfi Ali who has given me
many beatings is now seems like taking a
beating timewise and position wise
however looks like this rook is cooked
and we have a draw offer on the table
but it has been declined by white white
says excuse me black says no thank you
I want to play on and either milk the
time or kill your king okay what are we
gonna have here it looks like lemma
minute is going to be winning that one
right here why is a very fast and very
strong player but I don't know if
they're fast enough here where are they
wow they're actually catching up
timewise are you kidding me here no way
is white gonna pull this off Oh Oh the
rook Queen takes rook takes rook oh the
bishops cooked the Knights looking for a
new home 7 seconds to 2200 back ranked
rook takes Knight here for kirovsky on
f6 maybe pawn takes this is dead
uh-oh Knight here mate into threat
checkmate
there it is mate
okay let's cut out here let's see who
else's maybe taking a beating I think
they're all finished up yep okay let's
see the standings I got one and a half I
took I took my little draw and I ran
with it so I'm probably getting paired
with maybe this guy okay
Oh Bello Dilys maybe I have one and a
half I heard this is the guy I drew
against No okay I was ready to resign
again let's not reside I was right my
mouse gravitated over here
[Music]
okay here we go
here we go
let's not resign like I almost did in
that first game and I'm gonna go with
this right here this is a little bit
different than my norm so let's get my
bishop on b2 and we'll get c4 in in
Knight c3 and look for efore and d5 and
all that fun stuff I'm looking to get
the dark square bishop Soph the board
basically there I should probably be a
bit more general about the things that I
I share in these five minute ones
instead of the specifics so let's get
that in --see floor I want to control
the center a little bit
- what next night c3o this is all the
more appealing look at this pivoting
squares good stuff can happen let's get
my rook opposite the Queen
there could be night here in some
instances where's that Bishop gonna go
f5 where's the knight gonna go if I am
push see my opponent with a six is
getting ready to meet okay getting ready
to meet pawn push with like b5 if I
close it up in the center b5 but now how
do I recapture I think this might be a
nice shot Knight d5 Knight takes is no
good because the pin so 95 the Queen has
to go elsewhere but what about just this
right now I like that right now actually
I want to keep a clear Lane I want to
keep this diagonal open towards my
opponent's Bishop because this is
something I'm welcoming and I am alright
I believe with this right now if the
knight moves it's a losing move do you
know why right now it's not my bad my
bad there's somebody named my bad are
they here I was thinking like Queen
takes bishop and then king takes in the
Knight d5 discovered check and I get the
clean but I'm we're not we're not gonna
be having that so I think Bishop here is
a good idea Bishop here yeah let's go
with that I'm missing something
95 is not good because
boom-boom-boom-boom everything falls
into play then Bishop here hmm
interesting bishop d5 night if the night
takes maybe i get a flight square flight
square time right absolutely absolutely
go for a flight square right am I
missing something I'm actually up on
time what is up with that something's
clearly gone wrong if I'm up on time so
I have this still available that night
being able to be tricky there snip that
Bishop in some instances 95 cetera Oh
are they would they really ever fall for
something like that would they blunder
at 95 Oh that'd be sweet that would be
sweet 95 what else can they do
on a more serious note instead of hoping
that they make bad moves what is the
best continuation oh they did it this is
what I was talking about no way are they
listening to this stream and they just
wanted to see my reaction Queen takes
Bishop King takes it's all Forest Knight
takes Knight discovered check and then I
get to clean oh right Queen let me just
double check here for some reason I
think um I don't know I'm a little
paranoid are people playing tricks on me
here what's going on here Queen takes
Bishop King takes Queen Knight takes
Knight discovered check and then they
pick off the Queen I'm up a minor piece
there right and I'm up on time ah sneaky
sneaky sneaky sneaky I think we might
have resignation the clock is ticking
away nope can I get my knight here for
me no way or here that would be me but
no way the Queen's watching over so
let's do this and let's make sure of
what
let's make sure that I get right here
this square in particular by the way
because I want to have this supported I
don't want to be challenged on c4 not be
able to take so in a very important
detail and I'm going to be improving my
king position I want to get my king to
d2 and let's do this really quick really
really quick really really quick I want
to just make sure I stay ahead on time
and then what and then what a for Bishop
III Bishop III rook here and I run into
some problems
okay this rook is running the risk of
maybe getting trapped Bishop a3 to there
and what's what's there up doing there I
don't have to react to that let's do
this
for starters am I gonna miss something
now stay ahead on time oh I could be
taking this pawn as well yeah let's take
a pond let me take that pond oh that's
clean enough it well let's let's kick
that rook away first I don't want the
rook to be keeping pressure on that pond
so now I'm gonna take this and then come
back take a six and then just plate a b5
and everything is nice and cozy I'm
looking for those cozy positions there
we go my rook is here to guard even if
bishop here I could just play back right
everything is smooth let's just go a
single square and
right here
actually let's get this rook out of here
you know I'm really not liking that rook
let's get it off of this running here
okay let's do that is the rook out
running the risk of getting trapped I
think it might be actually let's uh
let's let my rook be freed up here and
[Music]
am I missing something here am I missing
something
I'm gonna plead playing f5 that our
Bishop is close to being dead and for
some reason it seems like it should be a
lot simpler okay where once again kind
of neck-and-neck with time and what is
going on here it should be much simpler
than this what is going on here
let me just figure this out um just take
okay it's not it's not very simple is it
can't it just can't be simple can it I
can't make it simple no come on you know
you want to keep it simple come on
okay please can we get this to work
somehow
soon oh okay this is seriously bad
technique let me tell you really really
bad technique here really bad technique
okay now I'm actually seeing finally
have some coordination finally and let's
trade
let's definitely want to trade here and
I could get this pun so okay I'm not
gonna lose this not gonna lose this now
that the smoke is cleared but again very
very bad technique very very bad
technique on my part
horrible Skippy hang on
is there still bad technique to be had
don't let them get the bishop I'm
getting the Queen okay time is equal
hang on hang on hang on
I could block with my bishop now let's
get this in this okay now it's coming
together let's hang on to that and
insert this check yes
no stalemate now hang on not over yet
okay finally ah was that ugly technique
or what oh I'm frustrated with myself
over that I hate that to be up a piece
like that in like a pond ah that bugs me
okay good game though good game all
right let me go back there's one more
round one more round let's see what's
going on this guy has three oh here we
go
this there's no time to even breathe ha
okay let's roll with something exciting
let's go down exciting here can I
somehow get a tie for first or maybe
second
so I actually maybe have a chance of
half a granola bar could I actually get
a Grand Prix attack in a quick kill
somehow a quick kill we will see we will
see okay now where does my light square
Bishop want to be let's try that okay I
think I'm happy with my position font
bush night back okay now I am definitely
happy with position sometimes just
voluntarily taking is good
prior to just even being provoked so I
would like to get some more development
in soon but I think Queen here is good I
actually reviewed this with someone a
while back and I think this is a correct
idea getting your queen to eat - lets
get castled and another idea is I think
to maybe pinpoint this pun so I'm gonna
try to do that in fact I'm gonna try to
get in c4 and that's one of the ideas
behind Queen to eat - lets get out of
any tricks along this dog you know we
don't want to have to deal with any
discovered checks
so now night 84 will come with tempo
whereas before I really it really
wouldn't be coming with tempo with it
and now we got b3 coming up and then c4
the main idea for me is to or the
demands of the position I believe are to
make sure you to restrain this light
square Bishop and I think I'm doing just
that right now so I could play here kick
this night away and I'm looking into
doing that right now Eve 5 let's do it
be 5 with the continuation c4 okay I
think my opponent is in big trouble here
there there Bishop is essentially a
prisoner and I want to reinforce that
point if they close it down I'm looking
for g4 next okay so now we have this
going on let's get my bishop here so
that there's no like takes and then it's
a problem over here
I would like to get my bishop here maybe
and I could maybe force that getting my
queen on this diagonal my attention is
now going to turn towards rook g1 okay
let's back up here I think things are
actually working out very well but I
think I'm seeing a cleaner plan my
bishop move was a mistake the correct
idea is to pinpoint this pun but no no
no no no no I'm not even gonna do that
tell you what I am gonna do my King is
gonna go for a little bit of a walk he's
gonna go for a walk he's going to take a
nice long stroll to the Queen side and I
think I could manage that so let's go
King
let's go King and hopefully my opponent
burns a lot of time while he's a taking
flight to that side of the board no I'm
seeing that this is possible because we
have a lot of stuff closed let's come
over here maybe I maybe my king wants to
sit on f2 maybe Queen to e1 if the pond
gets up there I think I just do what
with that let's come over here I'm being
sneaking actually this pawn push could
maybe be good but no they don't have
enough coverage for it and if they try
to get their Queen to da I might want to
get my queen to see one too just watch
over that notice how this Bishop is not
able to see any of my four ranks of the
board so let's get that King out of
there let's get rolling let us get
rolling here and now let's keep going
King you know you want to just come over
here so let's go oh they're making me
think twice about my decision maybe
maybe not we're gonna see Oh Oh putting
some pressure on me there all right
let's support that a little bit
I have more versatility I think let's
get this in I have a minute advantage
and maybe I want to chase the Queen
around a little bit or maybe not how
about I sneak in King bee to Keaney one
let's go my opponent wants a drum to
claim that I don't want to draw I want
to win I want to win there we go okay my
king is tucked in he's happy about that
let's go over here I guess actually no
no no no no no let's come over here a
lot of maneuvering a lot of maneuvering
I realize let's get this in slow and
steady so now where can I do better with
my knight maybe but wait let's do this
now I might want to pinpoint this pond
now that my king is over here the other
thing that kind of kept me from running
with that idea before was that I thought
that even if I get this pond even if I
get that pond I thought that you know
they eventually pushed this pond and
then my this light square diagonal
becomes an issue towards my king but my
king is nowhere to be found over here so
I'm remaining flexible on this side of
the board I'm working both sides of the
board right now and I'm looking for
Queen to a5 pinpointing c-54 a little
bit more and I think the position
crumbles if I am not mistaken right now
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight takes
I'm sneaking in this is bound to fall
is there a drawback with that however
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight takes
Queen a7 after I move the knight this
move comes and then the bishop sneaks
out in this direction hmm there might be
a drawback with that maybe I should
actually double up there's no maybe rush
with doing that so I'm looking for g4
still here we go I think I have
everything in place to get this advance
in and let me get my queen where okay I
got still have about a minute advantage
oh here's maybe a nice one let's do this
I'm looking for this move in then Knight
here see if I can make that happen here
we go gotta get that in let's see see
there you have to first recognize that
my opponent is in a position where they
can't really make progress and now that
this pond has is no longer the board
guess where this night might want to be
guess where this Knight would love to be
absolutely crushing d6
f6 c5 you name it bad things are
happening sneaking in and I have a time
advantage a minute advantage slow and
steady wins the race
check there's got to be mates my rooks
are on a closed file I can give a check
but I'm gonna reserve it H file now H
file again and I might want to set up in
alkynes battery now that the bishop has
left here
my dark square bishop could come to life
I can swing over to the King side the
Queen side over here if I need it I have
a ton of room a lot of space everything
is under control here next phase is what
I could probably just take here but I'm
not going to I'm gonna take one last
prep move do this get my queen to h2 and
it's dead Queen h2
mashing through there's no defense
there's too many squares to have to
watch in too little space to work with
three ranks and this isn't going to stop
me either
well let's come over here I don't want
to give up material just so fast I'm
more at my most my biggest concern is
just getting that dark square bishop
once the dark square Bishop Falls
there's absolutely nothing to do and
let's throw a check-in right now this is
leading to mate they resigned what do we
got first place are you kidding me
whoa did that guy lose or something I
was not expecting that are you kidding
me 60 crowns that's six granola bars oh
man I'll take that one then let me close
out of that all right I never did that
before on this fanatics I guess somebody
was right before with the whole um I was
like I never get first in somebody I
don't know who wasn't that twitchchat
said never say never
Wow I will take that what were the other
finishes here Amir startin star Caen Wow
tough field that was a well at the end
of it when it started it wasn't 2100
average rating but I guess right now
after there were the 22 players it was
average rating 2,100 Wow
again not expecting that good games off